today i'm going to be speaking with dr
eric topple who is
founder and director of the scripps
research translational institute
also a professor of molecular medicine
and
executive vice president at scripps
research it's so great to have you on i
really appreciate
it oh david great to be with you so
let's
let's maybe start with vaccination and
and kind of center our conversation
there
um we have currently uh two
approved vaccines in the united states
under emergency use
authorization for coronavirus the pfizer
biontech vaccine
as well as the moderna vaccine there are
other vaccines that have started to be
approved in other
countries all currently correct me if
i'm wrong
mrna platform vaccines
there has been much made of the short
amount of time
it has taken to get these vaccines this
is something that is merely a function
of the platform is that right
it just takes less time to develop a
vaccine under this paradigm
well a few things just to clear up there
so yes
the mrna platform did work very quickly
within days
of having the sequence of the virus that
was released
from the chinese scientist in january
within days there was already a template
for an mrna vaccine but there are some
other vaccines besides the two that you
mentioned
that have gotten approval on an
emergency basis in other countries
but they're not mrna so for example the
astrazeneca is an adenovirus vector
not an mrna um basically
and a couple of the chinese uh firm uh
and the russian
sputnik these are different they they're
not they're
they're using uh viral um
proteins rather than um the mrna which
is
basically just giving uh into the muscle
a message to make spike protein that's
modified
instead of the virus so it's perfect
because you don't have to risk
any virus it's just that one component
which is
an excellent target and by the way david
all the vaccines do have that common
thread
they use the spiked protein uh as the
primary target is there anything
what is import i'll say it more broadly
what is important
for the average vaccine recipient to
know
in terms of the differences for them
in receiving an mrna-based vaccine
versus the weakened or dead virus-based
vaccine
right so you know basically you have uh
two trials that came out first that were
very large you know forty four thousand
with the pfizer biontec
and thirty thousand plus with the
moderna they both had 95
efficacy they both had really good
safety profile
without uh concerns there at least out
to two months and that
should cover most of the uh concerns on
safety so
that's kind of the new reference
standard for the other vaccines
so the astrazeneca at the main dose that
it's been tested so far had an efficacy
of 62
when using a viral vector and then
others have come in at you know variable
levels but they haven't had as large
trial experience so what you really want
is a as a
vaccinee a person getting a vaccine
you want to know how high is the
efficacy how well was it tested was it
in really large trials with good
follow-up
these are important concerns because
we're seeing some
reduction in threshold for getting
approval because
obviously we're in a very dire situation
right now yeah
when we hear about numbers like 95
percent
as you are talking about um that would
suggest
that out of every 20 people that get the
vaccine one will not develop
sufficient uh protection against
an infection is it possible to know
through an antibody test whether you are
in that five percent and if so
would it be potentially uh something you
could do
in in looking at getting an another
vaccine if you get the moderna and
you're in the five percent
can you go and get the pfizer and maybe
you'll be in the 19 out of 20. right
right that's a really great question um
and actually i share your uh interest in
having a neutralization antibody test
we don't have one that would tell you
for sure that you're protected yeah
because it isn't a hundred percent in
the modern
trial which was interesting for severe
infections that would require
hospitalization
it was 30 versus zero so it looked like
it was a hundred percent but those are
very small numbers yeah
um but so one thing is you want to be
protected
and and there's not it's not yes or no i
mean you want to be protected from
most importantly is severe infections
but you want to be fully protected
there's another layer of concern here
that isn't settled
and that is you could get the virus in
your upper airway particularly your
your nose nasal lining mucosa
and you could pass it on without
that this is that term of mucosal
immunity or
sterilization immunity and so we don't
have a full
readout on that yet we have some
encouraging preliminary data
so yes you're right if we could find out
the people who didn't get
the ideal response you could try another
vaccine
that's right and we don't have any you
know commercial assay to get
the answer to your question david we i
wish we did because
then you would about two weeks or a
month after you got your second dose
right
you would get a checkpoint and then if
you
weren't um high levels of neutralization
antibiotic you would get another vaccine
that would be the ideal scenario
but nobody's talking about that you're
you're the first one
that's really brought that out yeah and
you when you start doing the math if you
say well what what are the odds that
if you've got a room of people uh i mean
i think if i understand the math
correctly
if you have a room of 20 people and you
vaccinate all of them
uh there's a five percent chance one has
no immunity
and it is it correct to say there's a
two and a half percent chance
that two of those 20 end up with no
immunity i mean is the math that simple
well it's not quite that uh
precise the reason is is that you know
these trials were really large
and we're only talking about a tiny
subset right who were the first ones to
cross the line and get infections
so the numbers as you get much larger
could be different i mean this is kind
of giving you a ballpark they were
highly significant
differences of course yeah but it could
turn out to be three percent
or seven percent you know we we don't
know okay there's another part of this
story that's interesting to point out
and that is
this the trials are the ideal experience
that is they're conducted you know
rigorously with how the vaccines are
given
but in the real world they may gotten
thawed out early
you know they may not have you know been
cared for the
the actual uh sterile the uh the
the uh uh glass uh uh violence
vials yeah good yeah thank you uh
you know that we're not kept in the deep
freeze or whatever so you see
it it may be a little different in the
real world
it usually isn't better it's usually a
little worse right
so in terms of uh i mean i'll be very
transparent i think the logistical
rollout so far has been pretty
disastrous there were promises of 100
million doses in 2020
then promises of 20 million vaccinated
today as we talk we have about four and
a half million
first doses that have been given out
with question marks around how much if
any immunity you get from from the first
dose it seems
it's probably some but but we don't
really know and the vaccine makers are
being careful to say
it's not been tested at what level
do you believe we are going to start to
see
and you can answer either or both deaths
and or
cases noticeably pulled down by
vaccination
right well it has been uh a terrible
shortfall so far as you as you
aptly point out david uh we were
expecting at least 20 million people to
have
had their first dose in december right
and we're not even at quite at 5 million
yet so
there there is an issue of course that
their vaccines have largely been
delivered
that is there's close to 20 million out
there now but they're just not getting
in people's arms
shots now to get this herd immunity
which is the only way to get to
uh herd immunity not through natural
infections through vaccines
we need to get you know at least
approximately 70 of people but the good
part in the united states
uh if there is a good thing here is that
we let this virus
go with rampant spread and so we have at
least 60 to 70 million people who have
natural infection-induced immune
response
so you believe that's important now so
that's about 3x the official cases you
believe the real infection rate is about
three times the official 20 million or
so that's right it was just published
today actually just before we got
together
in jama network open that uh it's at
least 3.2 x
of the numbers so we have 20 million so
we're about 65 million based on all the
the studies so the point here is that we
could get there faster go back to your
really great question about what if we
had a neutralization antibody to
the virus to the spike protein
uh if we had that and we could say
rapidly you
you have you're coming into your vaccine
you're you're in the line in the queue
and we tested you and a couple minutes
later said well you're good to go
you're you're good right now you don't
need the vaccine we need to defer
you until we get to 70
now if we could tap into that 60 plus
65 million people we can get there a lot
faster but if we don't do that
we're looking at you know uh third
quarter at best that means we got to get
to two to three million
vaccine uh people a day a day right plus
getting them all a second dose now
the j and j vaccine which is the
jansen's coming out uh you know perhaps
early february even later this month if
that clicks that's a single dose so that
will make life easier plus it doesn't
require freezing
that will make logistics easier and it
will also add to our vaccine supply but
overall we're not going to get to
population immunity
that we need the faster the better
especially with this new
strain this new b117
we got to go fast now this is a race
against a very
challenging formidable highly infectious
variant
one last question about the 60 million
that we believe
have have been infected already my
understanding is there's still a
question as to the the duration and
robustness of the immunity
for recovered patients and questions
about for example
if you had a really mild case is how
does your
degree of immunity compare to someone
who recovered from a more severe case
does it last three months six months
nine i correct me if i'm wrong
if if reinfection was really common we
would have
way more examples of it if the number is
60 million that seems clear but what do
we know about the duration of natural
immunity
yeah oh you're really on this this is
great so
um the reinfection story uh you know in
the world
we have like 35 documented cases okay by
genomics that you you sequence the virus
in the first infection second they're
very different
we know that it was a reinfection
there's probably considerably more than
that but if you think about the world
number of infections it's really low
now that be speaks the issue that
natural immune response to an infection
is
quite good okay so the interesting thing
is the vaccine is what we've written
about
as superhuman that is it's even better
and what i what i mean by that is the
average person
now that we've looked out long enough
has at least eight or nine
months of protection at least okay maybe
even years
but at least eight or nine months now
remember you pointed out five percent of
people with a vaccine don't have an
ideal response about
let's say with the natural response it's
more than that
it could be ten percent could be 12 you
know it's
it's it's more because a vaccine gets a
much higher level
of these neutralizing antibodies which
is the precious response that drives
your protection no less you know t
cells and and other you know response
that's part of the
um protection but most of it's the
neutralizing antibodies
so to answer your question i you know i
think what we're what we
can say is if you have a neutralizing
antibody
um if it's still there at good levels
you're you're good to be deferred i mean
you know you don't need a vaccine right
now
we need that for other people to get us
to this
because we we are unfortunately going to
face a vaccine shortage
unlike israel which is the lead you know
the pacesetter
they're going to have enough vaccines
they order early they have a supply
they have enough vaccines for everybody
yeah i believe i believe they're at 14
already yeah actually that was as of the
third as of today they're probably
they're going at least one and a half
percent a day so they're they're
probably at least 16 percent
they've they've now have all the
vaccines you know they need to get
everybody
vaccinated uh who's willing which is
most people of course there
unlike what we have which is some
hesitancy resistance anti-vaxxers
but even with our our our issues our
biggest problem is
getting shots in the arm getting the
second doses
at high scale you know like we did it in
1947 with smallpox
when we had six and a half million
people in a few weeks
we've got to be doing that now every day
throughout the country
so give us a few bullet points there's
so much that could be said about the
logistics that could be organized but
give us a few bullet points about things
that should be done right away one
anecdotal story
my stepmom works in healthcare but not
as a direct provider she works for a
company that that
you know in sort of management i guess
you would say and she got a call on
january 1st saying
listen we got vaccines for the first
responders
we have two vaccines left over there's
no system for us to
send these to a for nurses at a
different place
we just have two vaccines and they're
going to go bad do you want a vaccine
and she said
sure that multiplied by a hundred
million it
it seems inconceivably chaotic so like
what are the logistical things that need
to happen here
right well you know it is uh crazy that
we're not
just trying to do everything we can to
get vaccines into people
um and so we waste uh you know a lot of
shots um
obviously what you know once they're
they're thawed if they don't get
uh used they're they're lost and we just
don't want any of that to happen so
we need mass events you know we need uh
an all-out um effort to get
you know as a huge number of people
every day
throughout the country and that well
that's you know getting
stadiums uh and big facilities where
you know just people on an hourly basis
show up and quick you know get their
jab or whether it's mobile uh you know
uh efforts you know with with vans and
you know
whatever it takes obviously pharmacies
could help here
you know because they're pretty widely
distributed so the walgreens and cvs
they should be part of the story as well
but we need you know this idea that um
you know i have
high regard for the new administration
but they're talking about 100 million
vaccines in a hundred days well that's
only 50 million people in the 100 days
of the
new administration that's not neat yeah
it sounds so good
and yet the math of it is still falling
very short
absolutely yeah so that's just not going
to work we have to be a whole lot more
aggressive
and i hope that's going to change i i
hope so uh we've been speaking with dr
eric topel who is founder
and director of the scripps research
translational institute also a professor
of molecular medicine um
dr toppo such a pleasure having you and
i really appreciate your time i know
you're very busy
well i'm really impressed how well
you're on this david uh you you've
really
uh i didn't think you had a science
background but it sure looks like it
i don't my my uh formal training is in
business if you could imagine
no but i mean listen this is the it's
the issue of our time you know and uh
for my audience's sake i must remain
informed
well you're a fast learner great to meet
you and great to have a conversation